hey betches ok we're back and we are
going to mix mechanical strength and
that's dumb not ready to go to it oh
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] know that one or that
one out ok so where is it what something
right here hey Franklin wants to come
here let me begin at lonely and what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you Tanya ain't
nothing wrong with me [ __ ] [ __ ] well
your ass don't look too good where the
[ __ ] is JB smoking and what about you I
mean no I quit you know San almost yeah
baby look baby don't lose everything he
don't lose the house you don't stand the
business everything and you his cousin
[ __ ] you said you was all male my cook
whatever that's how you feel what the
[ __ ] do I know about come on Carla it's
easy if they be can do it you can do it
for [ __ ] sake come on i'ma show you
come on hard you everything sure let's
do this [ __ ] let's make this
quick I got [ __ ] to do [ __ ] you need to
slow it down Kenisha was right go to the
tow truck where is that [ __ ] Park to
come out and taking my car where you
will back the [ __ ] am I doing this let's
go even got no car
I see where we go trucks at the Davis
tariff impounds city bro how did I get
dragged into D we both know you always
this we owe me sit Franklin Clinton
joyous must be hard something I told you
I don't do that [ __ ] no mo I mean our
baby doze now on again just for the
taste but I'm doing good boo you are so
much whatever you say girl come on
and he breaks her heart
where's the coat check in here yes dance
baby truck let's go bring the church
dang homie Jesus why don't you do that
oh Jesus Kyurem the [ __ ] in Skyrim like
why is jump and leftovers glad we didn't
why I'm in this is dispatch we got an
abandoned cars that address have enough
yo we on that like ugly on your mama
said I'd come again I didn't it's time
you please and my boy Franklin we
feeling it bday be copy that hi Tanya
cars a junker been every day 10-7 of God
a bucket this one should be easy seeing
not easy enough for jb the Dragons rants
out of whatever crack house he laying in
his loss yo game sugar except I ain't
gay me [ __ ] he ain't gonna do this move
that seat back and you know I'll make it
right for you nothing what I'm saying
pale tiny what the [ __ ] happened to you
let that sit back down
squeeze in here sorry I that's whack
okay I've seen baby do this a hundred
times backup plus make sure the hook is
down and it is slide right
hi baby back it up night you gotta ok we
are any baby let's get this back to the
lot hey this is not how so monday going
man I love this [ __ ] approach [ __ ]
the man seen you around the hood much
I've been trying to branch out taste and
family healed forever Oh [ __ ] got heirs
now I remember you I remember you before
you wasn't wanna be when you just was
and I remember you and jb before you
always go pee [ __ ] change your the world
turns out maybe smoking but he ain't
smoking homie lines in towing cars
paying bills for real cuz i could have
sworn it with me on your toy cars for
here it's fully hard for he and looking
damn fine doing its too baby okay we
make the truck where they got the area
smart hey finicky when we don't leave it
in the right place Franklin look where
you going
okay you got it release that baby i'll
see you on the black anything you need
you hung at me now thanks for watching
thank you